c'est un événement assez unique parce
qu'en ce moment on parle beaucoup du
basket 3 contre 3 spool olympique il y a
des trous noirs organisés partout il y a
beaucoup de moi qui tiennent autour
alors nous on voulait faire un truc
différent on joue à 4 contre 4 et on a
fait un trou noir avec 12 équipes on va
arriver bientôt en finale et donc ça va
être le champion du jour il y a pas de
l'argent à gagner c'est que pour le fun
et on veut que ça soit surtout dans une
bonne esprit
ça c'est peu près 45 pour le moment il y
a très peu de membres mais nous avons
une grosse présence sur les réseaux
sociaux en fait tout est bénévole et
tout ce qu'on veut c'est proposer aux
municipalités de rénover du terrain de
créer des nouveaux terrains et de faire
les bons choix au niveau du matériel
justement
pour pas gaspiller de l'argent public
je peux coacher les jeunes je peux
participer à des événements comme ça à
notre association donc ça me permet de
rester dans le basket mais en tant que
joueur à 67 ans il était temps que je
m'arrête et mon dernier
crise cardiaque ma convaincu que c'était
le moment de stopper définitivement mais
bon j'ai eu de la chance qu'il y avait
un jeune Maxime Wang à côté de moi le
jour où je suis tombé en mont subite sur
un terrain de basket j'ai beaucoup de
chance et je reconnais la chance que
j'ai de pouvoir être ici aujourd'hui
face à vous
[Musique]